CHET HAASE: Good afternoon
and welcome to "What's
New in Android."
I guess this thing is
being live streamed,
so we should also
say good afternoon
to everybody else in the world.
DAN SANDLER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
CHET HAASE: That's right,
or something like that.
I am Chet Haase.
I'm on the Android
UI Toolkit team.
DAN SANDLER: I'm Dan Sandler.
I'm on the Android System UI
team in the Boston office.
Boston!
CHET HAASE: And thank you
for the overwhelming applause
there.
That was fantastic.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Thanks for coming.
That's all we've got today.
Goodnight.
So let's talk about, I don't
know, what's new in Android.
We want to talk
about API and things
like that, except we had the
idea that we should really
step it up this year.
DAN SANDLER: We need
to be inspirational.
We need to encourage people.
We need to open their mind.
We need API, functions
worth calling.
Sorry.
I've got to pose
for the picture.
CHET HAASE: So we're
going to talk about-- we'd
like to talk about
all of the new stuff,
but it turns out we really
don't have the time.
We put so much
stuff in the slides
that we basically spent
yesterday ripping out
about two thirds of it.
DAN SANDLER: There's, like,
another whole hour of talk
that we could do on
the director's cut.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Look for the deleted scenes.
There are a lot of them.
DAN SANDLER: Unrated.
CHET HAASE: So let's dive right
in and talk about some stuff,
starting with let's talk
about M. So a lot of people
are probably wondering
what M stands for.
I know we are.
Any guesses?
My personal guess is Mmmmm.
But today, more importantly, M
stands for M Developer Preview.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's talk about how to
actually build preview apps.
So first of all, get the tool.
So go to the site, get the tool,
download the SDK and Android
Studio 1.3, and you
create your project
the same way that you
always create your project,
and then you go in and you
modify the project structure.
What you're going to do is
build against Android M Preview,
not surprisingly.
And then if you look,
you don't have to edit.
Please don't edit.
Look in your
build.gradle profile.
It'll probably say something
like "complie SDK version
Android MNC," and then you know
that you're off and running
and you can use the new
APIs that we're going
to be talking about today.
So write the code, and
then obviously, you're
going to test it.
There won't be any bugs, but
if there are, you can debug it.
And then just go ahead and do
it again until you're done.
An extra thing
that we should add
is that the Preview
process this year
is a little bit different than
the Preview process last year.
We intend to actually have a
couple of different versions
out there.
So we're going to
incorporate the feedback
that we get, and we have some
issues that we know about
that we're working on still
internally, fix those bugs,
come out with another
Preview release,
fix those bugs from
that Preview cycle,
come out with another release.
And then sometime
after that dotted
line that's sufficiently vague
that we're not pinning down
a date on that one, we've
got a final release.
That's the Preview release.
Now let's talk about a
slew of APIs and features
in no particular order.
DAN SANDLER: In no
particular order,
but we do want to talk
about some of the things
that you saw in the
keynote, and one
of the first ones--
hopefully this
is exciting to all of
you-- is the changes
that we made in App
Permissions for M
to promote all
kinds of great stuff
around installing and upgrading.
So let's take a look at it.
You may recall this is what it
looks like when somebody wants
to install your app today.
It is a wall of permissions
because if your app has reached
a sufficient level
of complexity,
in addition to
being sentient, it
has to request
basically everything,
and the user says,
OK, fine, whatever.
It's not like I'm not going to
install Hangouts, let's say.
In M, we push the button,
and let's see what happens.
In M, runtime permissions.
So when you install an
app, you see none of that.
You click Install, it
downloads, it installs.
That's it, completely
friction free.
And then when the app
wants to go and use
some feature of the
device, then you
get the runtime
permission prompt.
For an app that is going to
use a bunch of permissions,
you know there's some things
without which it doesn't work--
if you've got a camera app, it
needs the camera-- we recommend
doing a warm welcome where
you ask for all those things
upfront.
But for other kinds of
permissions where you only
need it occasionally, like
recording audio in Keep
if you're going to
do a voice memo,
you can wait until the
right time to ask the user.
The user has ultimate
control over these things.
Not only can the user
deny them in the moment,
but they can go
back into Settings
and find out all the
permissions that your app has
and all of the apps that
have a particular permission
and turn them off individually,
line item a la carte.
That's a blank slide.
It's basically everything
that you've ever
asked for in
Android permissions,
and now your app
has to deal with it.
What does that mean in practice?
It means that you can ask for
any information at any time
if you're targeting M. If
you're not targeting M,
you don't get any of this stuff.
Legacy apps who
are not targeting
M, the experience they
will get is basically
what you have today pre-M, wall
of permissions at install time.
There's no other way to do it.
Users can go by and, for M
apps, deny those permissions
at the request time.
For legacy apps, they can
still go back into Settings.
For an app that has
not been updated to M,
if you are on an
M device, you can
go ahead and turn those
permissions off, even
for a legacy app.
There's a dialog box in Settings
that says, whoa, hang on there,
Tex.
This app has not been updated
to M. It might not work right.
But the user will still be
able to turn those things off.
So even if you don't have any
plans immediately to rev for M,
you need to test your
app in the M emulator
to find out what happens
when those precious, precious
permissions get
disabled by the user.
There is a session--
is it today?
Is it tomorrow?
It'll be on YouTube regardless.
CHET HAASE: It
might even be both.
DAN SANDLER: Might even be both.
"Permissions in M,
Best Practices."
You definitely
want to go to that.
They will get into all
the nitty gritty details
of how to ask for
permission at runtime,
what to do if you don't
get it, and so forth.
CHET HAASE: Actually,
for everything
that we're talking
about today, where there
is an applicable session or
sandbox talk at the conference,
we'll call it out and
suggest that you go there
for the deeper details.
As we said before, we
don't have a lot of time
to cover things in any deep
amount of detail ourselves,
so--
DAN SANDLER: Are you
telling me to hurry up?
Is that what you're saying?
CHET HAASE: I think
you're telling me to.
DAN SANDLER: I think so.
CHET HAASE: Let's talk
about one of those things
that we'll cover very, very
quickly, voice interaction.
So there is a new thing
called VoiceInteractor
that allows you to interact
with the voice input system.
So there was already
the capability
for a voice action of the
user to launch an intent
and do something with
your application,
but now you can actually
ask for clarifying
information or confirmations
that become maybe
audio responses to the user.
So you add this new category to
your intent filter, the voice
category, and then in your
code, you could already do this.
You could say, was this
a voice interaction?
Go ahead and do some stuff.
But now you can
actually say, well
actually, here's a string
to create a prompt out of.
Pass this back through creating
the confirmation object.
You're going to create a
voice interaction confirmation
request.
And then the prompt
goes back to the user,
they do something
with it, and then
the information comes
back to your activity,
you get the appropriate
information,
take the appropriate action.
DAN SANDLER: Let's
talk about Fingerprint.
We saw a lot of
this in the keynote.
It's actually
pretty simple APIs.
There are two major
ways to get into it.
One, you can talk to the
brand new Fingerprint Manager
in the Android Hardware
Package, I believe,
and you can say,
hey, authenticate.
What this does is it verifies
that the authorized user is
present and is able to provide
one of the multiple enrolled
fingers on the
fingerprint sensor.
So you can enroll.
You can say, I want this
finger, I want that finger.
And this manages to check
to see whether the user can
provide one of those fingers,
again, on the sensor.
But your app controls
all of the UI.
So if you want something
that's branded,
if you've got your
own fancy animations,
you can do all of that.
This is all completely
behind the scenes APIs
that you can call to
read from the sensor.
If, on the other
hand, you don't really
need to bother with
the UI and you just
want to make sure that
the user is still there,
you can use the existing
Keyguard Manager
API Create Confirm Device
Credential Intent, essentially
show the lock screen again.
Show the lock screen
and allow the user
to authenticate by
whatever means they usually
use to get into the device, so
a pin or a password or a pattern
or, on devices that
support it, a fingerprint.
You do this to start
activity for result,
you check for the OK result,
and then you're good to go
and you know that
the user is there.
We have sample code up on
the Google Samples section
of GitHub, Android Fingerprint
Dialog, Android Confirm
Credential, and there's
also a sandbox talk
about this today and tomorrow
about fingerprint and payments
APIs.
We don't have time to
talk about pay right now.
Go to that sandbox talk.
Learn more.
CHET HAASE: Let's
talk about backup.
So we already back up a
bunch of stuff on the system.
You get a new device,
you get settings
that are associated
with your account,
so we back up things like
Wi-Fi settings between devices
and accounts.
So all of that
stuff already works.
So the new thing in M is by
default, all the data for all
the apps that are
targeting M and greater
is going to be backed up
automatically by default
and then stored in
the user's account.
You have the ability to opt
in and out of various portions
of that if you want, so we can
see some simple sample code
here.
So you can specify
an XML file that's
going to live in your
XML resource directory
and then use these
Include and Exclude
tags to say what exactly
you want backed up
or what exactly you
do not want backed up.
By default, everything
is backed up,
but if you use an Include tag,
then we will only do that,
or everything's backed up
and you use Exclude tags
and we're going to pull
those things out and not
back those up at your choice.
Again, sandbox talk
that you should go to,
"Unleashing the Power
of Android Backup,"
so check that out
in your schedule.
Let's talk about
Google Play Services.
7.5 is out.
I hope it's out, or maybe we
should just delete this slide
before I talk about it.
DAN SANDLER: No, no.
CHET HAASE: Let's assume
that it's out by now.
Let's talk about one of
the most exciting features
there is GCM Network Manager.
If anybody's familiar
with Job Scheduler,
a very cool way of making
sure that your network
traffic, your network requests,
are going to be much more
optimal for the
device in general.
You're going to batch
these things up.
You're only going to do them
at certain optimal times
when the device is charging,
when it's on Wi-Fi, whatever.
That was awesome but it's
specific to L. GCM Network
Manager takes that same
idea and extends it
to releases prior to that.
Everybody that's opting
into this system,
it'll be able to batch up
all those requests together.
Then on L, it will use the
underlying Job Scheduler
technology and APIs, but
on previous releases,
it uses its own home animation--
I'm talking about animations
again even when I shouldn't be.
DAN SANDLER: We really
can't stop you, can we?
CHET HAASE: I don't know.
Implementation.
I'm going to use the word
"implementation" instead.
That works a little
better in this context.
I'm going to go with that.
So it's going to use its own
stuff internally prior to L,
and you're going to get
similar functionality
across many releases,
so check that out.
Also check out many of the
other things in the latest Play
Services release.
You've got Maps on Android Wear,
some of the other stuff listed
on the slide.
More importantly, go to the
"What's New in Google Play
Services" session.
I believe that's two
from now this afternoon,
so check that out for
deeper information.
DAN SANDLER: Let's
talk about power.
Do you want more power?
Sure, we all do.
In M, the focus has been
on improving battery life,
specifically improving
screen off battery life.
A device that you're not
holding, not plugged in,
it should be able to sit
there for kind of a long time.
In the keynote, you
heard about Doze,
which is the big new
device-wide feature that
is helping us with this.
Essentially, a device that is
untouched for a long period
of time becomes inactive.
We're actually using
the accelerometer
to see if you are actually
moving this device around.
If it's in your pocket,
this doesn't count,
but a device that is
sitting on the table,
sitting on the couch, sitting
in a bag for a long period
becomes inactive and waits
longer and longer to wake
up for scheduled repeating
events and things like that.
Now, as Dave said, if
there are real time alarms,
if there are high
priority GCM tickles,
things like that, sure, we'll
wake the device up immediately.
We don't want to miss
an important text.
CHET HAASE: Also earthquakes.
DAN SANDLER: Well, OK.
You work on that app
for the accelerometer.
And then as soon as
you pick up the device,
start interacting with it in
some way, even plug it in,
Doze turns off, the device
goes back to syncing as normal.
We're going to take
the same idea as well
and apply it to individual
apps that you haven't used
for a long period of
time, and by long, I
mean more on the order of days.
We call this app Standby.
So an app that you
installed a long time ago,
you kind of forgot about
it, you're not using it.
After a while,
it's going to lose
network access and the
ability to do other background
tasks so it can't sit there
and just continually sip
away at the coulombs
hiding in your battery.
So that app is going to go
dormant until you use it again
or until the device
gets plugged in.
Let's talk about what we saw
in the keynote as Now on Tap.
In the APIs, you'll
see this is called
Support for an Assistant.
In order to talk
to the assistant,
we have some new APIs that
you can look at on activity
in applications
so you can provide
very specific information
that you think
is going to be relevant to
something like Now on Tap
to be able to provide you just
in time help for the user.
So what you're
going to want to do
is see the SDK docs as part
of the M Preview release
to figure out how to use
those and integrate those
into your app to
provide the best data.
CHET HAASE: Data binding, one
of the most exciting features
to come out of the
toolkit arena right now.
It's an idea that's been
around in various forms
elsewhere for years,
and we're incorporating
some of those ideas here,
where it's the ability
to connect the data model
to some of the UI elements
in your application.
This is something
that you do already.
An application that's
all UI and no data
is basically a demo app.
That's what I write.
I write demo apps.
But real applications
should actually have data,
and when they do, you want
to propagate that information
to the UI, and when
it changes, you
need to propagate the changes.
And you end up
creating listeners,
you end up creating property
change notifications.
You've got setters and
getters all over the place
in your code.
It's not difficult
code to write but it's
a lot of tedious
boilerplate that you write
over and over and over again.
Wouldn't it be nice if we
could actually do that for you?
So that's the idea
behind data binding.
Let's take a simple example.
I think this is
an example that's
going to be used in the sandbox
talk that you should go to.
There's one this afternoon
and one tomorrow as well.
So you've got this idea where
you've got some pictures
and you have prices
associated with the items that
are shown in the pictures.
So you probably have some
item in your RecyclerView
that's binding to some
TextView and ImageView.
Through data binding,
we don't have time
to go through the
entire example,
but I can show you
the end result.
You end up having this
new type of resource
file that we've defined
called a Layout.
It's not a view layout
but it's an overall layout
that has both the view
hierarchy information as well
as this section of
data that you associate
with that view hierarchy.
So here, you can see that
we have the layout file
and then we have this variable.
We said, OK, we're going to
have this item thing that we're
going to call Item that
we can refer to, then,
within the file, and then
we have the ImageView
and the TextView that
can automatically
bind to the data in there.
So using this simple
language, they
can say OK, give me the field in
there and bind to that instead.
And they can also do
additional processing on that
so they can actually
format the string,
pick up a string format object
from the Strings resource file
and attach that to extra
information associated
with several variables.
So very powerful, very
simple, and also very
performant because
all of the hard
work is actually
done at build time.
So it takes all the information
created in your resource files,
preprocesses that into
the code that's actually
going to run at runtime.
So we're not doing anything
tricky like using reflection
at runtime, which you
really wouldn't want to do.
Instead, we preprocess this
into very efficient mechanisms
that work fast enough
at runtime for you.
So please check out
the talk in the future.
Let's talk about some more--
[APPLAUSE]
Yay data binding.
DAN SANDLER: Fans
of data binding.
Awesome.
We found our crowd.
These are our people, Chet.
CHET HAASE: You
know, they should
have talked about data
binding in the keynote.
When we talked about
keynote items, no applause.
Data binding, big applause.
We're going to go back,
we're going to rewind,
we're going to redo
the keynote, and it's
going to be all
about data binding,
two and a half hours
on data binding.
DAN SANDLER: We'll
fix this in post.
CHET HAASE: That's right.
Excellent.
All right, UI features.
This is a mix of stuff,
the most important of which
is probably the Android
Design Support Library.
Again, there's a
sandbox talk you
should go to to find out
the specific details there.
So with material
design, we had lots
of suggestions and
patterns and said,
this is the new
way to do things.
And then developers went
forth and did things
and they wrote a lot
of code in the process
trying to figure out.
Everybody was doing
their own implementation
of this and that.
What we're trying to do
with the Design Support
Library is embed some of those
practices into these components
that we then just give you.
And you can use these,
hopefully get up
to speed on material
design a little bit faster
and use our implementation.
It's going to be a
little more consistent
and it's certainly going to
be a little bit easier for you
to do that.
The first of which
is worth mentioning,
the Coordinator Layout.
This is something
that associates
the views, the hierarchy, and
then the behaviors of those
views in there.
Several of the components
that we're talking about here
plug into the
coordinator layout so
that they can interact
together and participate
in this common playground.
We have the Snackbar component,
we've got TabLayout widgets,
we've got NavigationView,
TextInputLayout.
This is the ability
to actually see
some text that says
what you're supposed
to be doing with this thing, as
well as some error validation
text in there.
And then the FAB.
Everybody always asked us
for the FAB, and we're like,
it's just a circle
with a shadow,
but apparently they wanted it.
DAN SANDLER: Now it's
an inspirational circle
with a shadow.
CHET HAASE: It's
very inspirational.
I'm inspired.
Some other random UI changes.
There's work ongoing
in RecyclerView,
powerful new replacement-ish
for a list view
that came out in
the last release.
There's other features
and functionality
going into that, so just swipe
to dismiss and drag and drop,
and some new animations
associated with that.
See, animations work there.
DAN SANDLER: They did.
CHET HAASE: So animations
in its implementation.
And then we have some changes
in WebView PostMessage
so you can have the
ability to interact
between WebView and JavaScript
and post messages there.
We also have more
diagnostic capability
around WebView clients,
and also the ability
to pre-render to an off
screen raster in a situation
where otherwise it might
flicker on the screen
during an animation.
It takes up more memory.
There's a trade
off between memory
and preserving those
bits more solidly,
so you can make the right
decision for your application.
DAN SANDLER: And
all that stuff is
in the SDK docs as well as
part of the M Preview release,
I believe.
Yes.
CHET HAASE: Notifications.
Why don't you talk
about notifications?
DAN SANDLER: You
thought you were
going to get away without
me giving you a notification
lecture, but this is my baby.
I'm going to talk
about notifications.
Fortunately, there
isn't nearly as
much to take in as
there was in Lollipop.
Lollipop was kind of
a bumper crop for us.
In M, the first thing I need
to explain is a new class.
Chet let me work in his team's
package for a little while
and build something called Icon.
Icon is not all
that complicated.
That's why I built it.
All it does is hold either
a drawable resource ID
or a bitmap or a
byte array that you
promise contains a
compressed bitmap of the sort
that bitmap factory can decode.
Why do we need this?
Because now, when you
build a notification,
you can just pass one of these
Icon objects to set small icon.
You are using the
builder, right?
Nobody's calling Set
Latest Event Info anymore?
CHET HAASE: Who's
using the builder?
DAN SANDLER: That's right.
CHET HAASE: Who's not
using the builder?
DAN SANDLER: I'll
see you outside.
CHET HAASE: Get out.
DAN SANDLER: That's right.
So great, Dan.
So you took what was
one line of code,
Set Small Icon of a resource ID,
and now you've made it three.
Now I have to construct
this other icon.
By the way, the old Set Small
Icon API does still work.
We don't deprecate APIs
that fast around here.
How long does it take
before we can actually
kill a deprecated API?
CHET HAASE: Three
milliseconds-- no.
DAN SANDLER: 17 milliseconds.
No, wait.
That's a frame.
CHET HAASE: We're
going to drop a frame.
That's true.
DAN SANDLER: OK, that's good.
No jank, not on this stage.
OK, Dan, why do we bother?
Why is this important?
I told you that an icon
can contain a resource ID.
It can also contain a bitmap.
You can use a bitmap so the
first time as the small icon
in a notification.
So if you've ever written an app
that posts notification icons
like these and you've had to
cut 60,000 assets to contain
every combination of
weather and temperature,
although for California
users, obviously,
you just need the one, now
you can generate these things
on the fly using a bitmap.
If you download an asset
from your web back end
or something, an avatar icon
or something and it's a ping,
you don't even need
to decompress it.
So this actually saves memory.
This saves time moving
things between processes.
I'm pretty excited about it.
CHET HAASE: Ladies and
gentlemen, icons with bitmaps.
DAN SANDLER: There we go.
That's right.
[APPLAUSE]
Sometimes, it's
the little things.
CHET HAASE: Who knew?
DAN SANDLER: Who knew?
Let's move on.
CHET HAASE: Let's talk
about some text stuff.
A couple of different
interesting changes
going on there.
First of all, the gestures
around text selection
have been improved, make
it a little bit faster
to choose things more
accurately and more quickly.
So you drag the handles out
and as you expand the area,
you expand by word,
and as you contract,
you contract by character.
So you can have
the same precision
but you can also select
larger blocks of text
much more quickly
than you could before.
Also, I want to point your
eyes to the screenshot
where you can see the
floating palette of actions.
This is maybe not such an
issue on a small phone screen,
but if you're using
a large tablet device
and you select
text way down there
and then you have to
reach all the way up
to the top of the screen
to hit the action bar,
sometimes it's so tedious for
we people that don't actually
get much exercise
during our coding days.
DAN SANDLER: My arthritis, yeah.
There's no way.
CHET HAASE: So what we have
now are floating palettes,
and we've enabled this
by default in TextView.
So you've got a TextView up,
which this example is from,
and you select the text and
automatically, the floating
palette of actions
is right there.
If you have other views that
are not these default TextViews
that we enable this for, you
can set your own action mode,
get the same behavior.
We also have the
ability to process text.
So you can create the
capability in your activity
to receive this
information to say, oh,
they just selected this text.
What would you
like to do with it?
You can translate
that information,
you can replace
the word for them,
you can send back
other suggestions,
you can do other things with
the text that got sent in,
so check out the new
text processing APIs.
And also, there was a lot of
work done with both performance
to enable this higher
quality formatting, as well
as the formatting itself.
So we have the
ability to format text
much more nicely
with hyphenations,
and also to shape that text.
DAN SANDLER: Hey, Chet.
I think people have
been watching for an API
like this for a while.
CHET HAASE: Have they?
So you know what this means?
DAN SANDLER: I do.
CHET HAASE: All right.
Well, there it is.
We're done.
You may be wondering,
why would you want
your text in a circular format?
DAN SANDLER: We did
this joke already.
We already-- all right,
let's start again.
I'm Dan.
CHET HAASE: I was
doing a different one.
DAN SANDLER: I see.
CHET HAASE: Parallel jokes.
App Linking go.
DAN SANDLER: So App Linking.
We touched on this a
little bit in the keynote.
The problem that
we're trying to solve
is one that we created
with an amazing feature
in Android, that is to
say, intent filters.
You as an app can say,
by the way, these URLs,
I know what to do with them.
You're expecting that the user,
having had an app installed
that knows how to handle
a particular URL subset
can do the right thing with it.
But sometimes you have an
app and you have a domain
and they're owned by
the same developer,
and that relationship
is stronger,
and so App Links are
about understanding
that relationship.
We've got documentation about
this on the Preview site
as well.
So what we're going
to do with App Links,
the way that you
establish the link
that you saw in the keynote
where a URL goes directly
to your app if you also
control that domain is you're
going to have two files.
One, you're going to have
a Statements declaration.
We put that on the website
in a well known location,
specifically .well-known.
It's a bundle of
JSON that includes,
among other things,
the APK package
name and the certificate hash
that you extract from Keytool.
You'll note that here in the
example, it's HTTP example.com.
That'll be HTTPS by
the time M is finished.
You put the statements
JSON up on your web server,
and then in your manifest-- wow.
That jumped quickly.
What happened there?
There we go.
In your manifest, you
say Android Auto Verify.
That's all you do.
You add that to
your existing intent
filter that can
handle certain URLs,
and now we will go and look for
that statements.json manifest
from your manifest.
So here's what happens
at install time.
When your app goes in,
the Package Manager looks,
sees Auto Verify, will
go to the website,
try to pull down
statements.json,
match that hash to the sign
in certificate on your APK.
And if everything works out just
fine, an App Link is created
and now links to those
URLs will open in your app
without bringing up the
intent disambiguation chooser.
If anything fails about
that, if the website
doesn't have statements.json, if
the certificate doesn't match,
if the package
doesn't match, nothing
happens, you revert
to the old behavior,
and those URLs will pop
up an intent chooser that
allows you to pick between the
browser or the various apps
on the device that can
handle that URL stem.
And of course, as with
everything else in M,
the user can take control.
You can go and review and modify
those App Links in Settings.
[APPLAUSE]
CHET HAASE: Can we
talk about sharing?
Let's talk about Direct
Share, which is the ability
to share deeper information
about your activity,
or specifically, deeper
links into your activity
when appropriate.
So wouldn't it be nice
if someone clicked
on something, it
fired an intent,
and you actually had
some context around that
and could actually share
something more interesting?
So instead of launching your
overall chat application,
you could actually
launch the conversation
that was in progress
with the contact
that they just clicked on.
Wouldn't it be nice
if you could offer
alternatives that appeared
in the Chooser dialog
like this stuff?
So here's how you do it
through Direct Share.
You provide information
with your intent filter
about chooser target service.
You say, when you're going to do
this intent, launch my service,
and my service can
be defined like this.
Say, it's a chooser
target service
and you're going to
implement that service
and override this
method and say,
when this method is called,
I'm going to return potentially
a list of possible
targets, including
maybe the overall
activity and some
of the deeper
activities, the deeper
links that are appropriate.
And then what
you're going to get
is something more
like this, where
you have the typical activities
at the bottom that were already
listed before.
We already have this
capability, but maybe
some of these deeper
links up at the top
that are more appropriate
to the context
that the user was actually
interested in at the time.
DAN SANDLER: Let's talk a little
bit about support for stylus.
We actually supported
styluses since way
back in Ice Cream Sandwich.
We've had constants in
the MotionEvent APIs
to allow you to detect that
a particular touch stream is
actually not coming
from a finger
at all but coming
from a stylus tool.
We've got buttons
that you can query
to see if they're being
depressed, pressure and size
data as well.
Now, of course, as
many of you know,
you can get some of that
pressure and size data
out of a piece of capacitive
glass, but for a stylus,
you get accurate information.
Unfortunately,
until now, this only
worked for a wired digitized,
like a tablet that you plug in,
or a built in active digitizer,
like a device with its own pen.
So what we've brought in
M is a couple of things.
First of all, a
declaration that you
can create a data stream,
Bluetooth HID over GITT.
If you're a Bluetooth LE person,
that means something to you.
CHET HAASE: No, no, no.
Bit gat bat.
Get over bat.
DAN SANDLER: Chet crashed.
We're going to have
to restart him.
If you send your
pressure and button data
over the HID protocol
over BLE, Android M
will fuse this with
touch data on the glass.
What this means is you can
build a Bluetooth stylus
that then is
reported as a stylus
to any app on any M device
that supports Bluetooth LE.
You don't need special
hardware that's
dedicated to that device.
The app does not
need to be revised
to support a particular
type of stylus protocol.
It just gets touch stream
events through motion event,
and if you are aware and
you care that it's a stylus,
you can interrogate that data.
So this is stylus support for
every app in every M device,
given the correct hardware
on the stylus side.
Wow.
This is doubled up.
Thank you.
We've got one more.
It's taken a couple bumps here.
I may need to ask you to do it.
CHET HAASE: Do you
want me to use that?
You need some practice
with that clicker.
DAN SANDLER: All right.
Watch it.
I do want to point
out that we're also
adding a couple
revisions to MotionEvent
in M to help you
deal with styli.
For one, we're going to have
Action Button Press, Action
Button Release, which
we didn't have before.
Previously, you would
have to just check
to see what the button state
was when you got another motion
event.
We've also introduced
new constants
for the primary and
secondary stylus button
which map to the secondary
and tertiary input device
button using the previous API.
So if you were looking
at secondary before,
you're going to get
stylus primary now.
It'll all be in the docs.
We also have new
gesture support.
So you can use Scale
Gesture Detector to enable
a stylus scale gesture.
Click the button and drag.
It's very much like the tap
and a half drag scale gesture
that we support in a lot
of apps on Android today.
And you can also add a
listener for specifically
when the stylus
button gets pressed
to make it really easy to do
things like picking up objects
and drag and drop them.
And now's the time
for the next slide.
CHET HAASE: Now let's talk
about graphics and media.
RenderScript compute, some
incremental changes there.
So support for BLAS.
Who knows what BLAS is?
Of course, basic linear
algebra sub-programs.
DAN SANDLER: I think there
were actually crickets in here.
Did you notice?
CHET HAASE: I think
they were dead crickets.
Really big matrices
for calculating really
big things, allocation-less
launches so you
can have the size of the kernel
that's now directly associated
with the data itself,
and ScriptGroups, more
optimizations for
launching these things that
then will execute together.
In the Camera API,
there's other camera
to API changes that we're
not going into here.
I would suggest you
check out the docs
to learn more interesting
information there.
But I did want to mention
the new Torch capability.
It allows you to have flashlight
capability in your app
without actually owning and
running the camera device.
It used to be hard coded,
linked with the camera,
and you had to get this really
heavyweight and battery sucking
thing running when all
you really wanted to do
was light up the flashlight.
Now it's associated
with the camera
but you're not actually
running the camera full time
while the flashlight is on.
So a new, simple API to
interact with that there.
Are, some important
optimizations
in the arena of Alpha.
This is a really
small and subtle thing
that ends up being a
real performance problem
that we see on our group a lot
where people will associate
Alpha with a TextView.
Sometimes when people
just want gray text,
they'll set it to
be white but then
they'll set a translucency
value on a very large TextView,
causing performance problems in
things like notification panel.
DAN SANDLER: [CLEARING THROAT]
CHET HAASE: So when we detect
that internally and someone's
set a translucent
value on a view,
then we can turn that into a
hardware layer automatically,
which is a lot faster for
us to then just create
the layer once, draw to it, and
then make that translucent, as
opposed to redrawing this
external buffer every time
we process the drawing
for that thing.
So we do this automatically.
However, we still suggest that
you set a layer type manually
whenever you actually need it.
It's a better
approach in general.
So you can use the Set
Layer Type in View.
You can also use the With Layer
API in View Property Animator.
Specifically, the
reason to do this
is because we're going to
create that layer the first time
that we know you need it,
but if that first time
is the first frame
of an animation,
you're going to suffer
a little bit of jank,
a little performance hiccup
as we create and render
that layer.
So it's better for you to do
it ahead of time than for us
to do it automatically
for you lazily.
DAN SANDLER: My four-year-old's
favorite color is clear,
so she's really excited
about this new API.
CHET HAASE: She's
so transparent.
Let's talk about audio
quickly, quickly.
MIDI.
So you could already
do MIDI if you wanted
to do it all by yourself.
So you're down there at the USB
level getting the byte stream
and doing everything you
could all on your lonesome.
So instead, we introduced the
new android.media.midi package
to do a lot of the
heavy lifting for you.
So we'll give you the
actual byte stream.
You still need to figure
out what the codes are.
That's kind of the
way MIDI works.
But you can create
a Device Manager,
you can create the Input
and the Output port,
send information,
get information,
create a MIDI service that
can listen for information
coming into the system.
And it's important to note it's
both sides of the equation.
You can have an Android app that
is sending the note information
out to samples on some external
device that are playing those.
You can also have a keyboard
or other MIDI device connected
through USB to
the Android device
and it's actually sending
the note information in,
and maybe your app is actually
playing the samples directly.
So two way communication.
That's what music is all about.
Also higher resolution audio.
There's always work going
on in the quality arena.
So we have audio
samples that are now
single precision float instead
of the 16-bit samples we
had before.
We have 96 kilohertz sample
rate instead of the 44.1 or 48
kilohertz, and we have
multichannel USB digital audio.
So yay.
Let's talk a little
bit about tools.
Android Studio 1.3.
They talked about
this in the keynote.
Integrated testing support,
data binding, yay, tooling,
especially syntax, understanding
for some of the new language
stuff that you saw in
the XML resource file
that we were looking at, some
tooling support around vector
drawables, new annotations
all the time to make it easier
to get more type safe code and
more information from the ID
itself, and also
Android NDK development.
You heard this stuff about
native code development
within Android Studio.
Please go to the next
session after this one.
Tor and folks were convinced
that we're basically
the warm up act for them, so we
encourage you to stick around
for the lead act in the band.
So go to their session
immediately following this one,
I believe in this room.
And Systrace.
So who agrees with me
this is a simple UI?
I get it.
It's obvious.
One person.
Excellent.
You, sir, are insane.
DAN SANDLER: It might
be Dave Burke, actually.
CHET HAASE: What's that?
DAN SANDLER: It
might be Dave Burke.
CHET HAASE: It could be.
So Systrace is probably the
most powerful performance tool
that we have, certainly in the
graphics performance arena.
It gives you a broad
spectrum of here's everything
that was going on in
the system that we
know about at the time when you
were experiencing performance
problems.
But it's difficult
sometimes to know
what to do with that information
because some people think
this is not obvious to look
at this obviously beautiful UI
and understand what was
actually going on in the system.
So what we did was we added
even more information to it.
Can I borrow that laser pointer?
So if you'll see up
here-- can you get
me a laser pointer that works?
Those little circles
in the middle
there are basically tips.
You can click on those to get
more information about what
was actually going on.
So we're preprocessing
the information there
to diagnose some of the
common performance problems
that we've seen and explain to
you what's actually going on
so that you have something
more actionable to do
besides staring at
your Systrace output.
So here's an example.
So you might click on
that red button down there
and you might get
something like this.
So you're going to
click on the red button
and it's going to highlight
the things that it's analyzing,
the problems that it
saw, and then it's
going to give you a little
annotation down at the bottom
and say, here was the problem
that we diagnosed there.
You are actually
during inflation,
you're stalling the UI thread
while you're doing this.
This is a bad thing to do.
Shame on you.
And then over on the
right, we have a summary
of all of the
problems that we saw,
buckets of the various problems.
In general, what we see
in diagnosing applications
internally is that by fixing
a couple of key problems,
you're going to knock out
most of these problems.
It's like when you
get compilation errors
and there's 4,000
compilation errors,
and then you fix one bug and
now you're down to only 3,947.
So there are several
common problems
that you might run into that
are sourced in one problem area.
So check out the buckets,
check out the notations there,
and go optimize your
application, please.
DAN SANDLER: Let's talk a
little bit about the compiler.
I remember my grad
compilers class,
which means that I sort of
remember what these things are.
The ART team is
continually working
on improving the new runtime.
The upshot of all this
stuff, the register allocator
and things like this, the
inlining and so forth,
the biggest impact, in addition
to just faster running code,
is improved memory
use particularly
on low end devices.
Every time they improve
one of these things,
you get back megabytes of
memory in your process.
It's really important.
We also have a new get
runtime stat API inside ART
so that you can go
and actually find out
a little bit of
the details about
what's going on in the runtime.
CHET HAASE: And some other stuff
that we really couldn't find
appropriate categories for.
We'll go through
this really quickly.
External storage, the ability
to adopt permanent storage
as one of the devices that
you want to use on the system.
So users can do this and then
move things around there.
The important key is two things.
One is there's no new APIs.
You don't need to do anything
but you do need to test.
So make sure that
you're not hard
coding the locations
of your app or your app
data or other
resources that you're
using, because what happens
if the user adopts one
of these devices,
moves stuff around,
and your app can no longer
find what it needs to function?
So there are no Preview devices
with this capability right now
because the devices that
we have system images
for don't have these devices
that you can actually
adopt permanently, these
permanent USB devices.
So instead, you can attach
temporary USB storage
and test it with the commands
that we have down here,
the Set Prop Persist
FW Force Adoptable
One, but that's
obvious, isn't it?
All right.
Developing for Android.
So I pushed this
right before the talk,
and probably right
after the talk,
I'll find out that
I shouldn't have.
But in the meantime,
you can check this out.
So a lot of the folks
in the platform team--
runtime folks, maps
folks, framework,
UI toolkit-- got together.
People will ask us questions
all the time about the best
approach for doing this
or that, or we find out
about ways that people are
accessing memory or creating
objects or hitting the network
or whatever and we say,
don't do it like that, and
then they would say, well,
how should we do it instead?
We don't like to
answer those questions
because we're really busy.
So instead, eventually,
we got together
and we wrote an
incredibly long article
with our brain dump of
a lot of the basic rules
that people should know about.
We put this into an article
that was entirely too
long to publish in its entirety
so we broke it into chapters
and we pushed the first
two right before this talk.
They're on Medium.com in the
new Google Developers channel
community thing.
It's on the new Google
Developers thing on Medium.com.
Please check those out.
We'll be pushing the rest of the
chapters in the next few days
and you can follow us on G+ to
find out where they are or just
go to the Google Developers
community and you will see them
there.
So what are you waiting for
besides the end of this talk?
Please go check out the Preview,
please download the bits
for the SDK, as well
as Android Studio.
Get the system image in
Flash appropriate devices.
Please report bugs.
The whole point of
having preview releases
is not just to tease you
with what we're working on.
It's actually to have
you run it in situations
that we may not be
testing internally
and then to get the feedback
from you about what you need
or what problems you saw.
And then finally, we
mentioned the sandbox talks
and the sessions at Google
I/O, but the DevBytes are maybe
even more important than the
sandbox talks because those
are actually going to be
recorded and pushed out
over the next 100
days or something.
There's going to be
a lot of DevBytes
around a lot of the
technical details and things
that we talked about today.
So please check those out
on the Google Developers
channel starting now and then
going through the summer.
And I believe that's it.
We have one minute and
10 seconds for questions,
and probably zero
time for answers.
DAN SANDLER: I don't think that
that's really going to happen.
People are going
to take that long
to get up to the microphone.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
DAN SANDLER: However, we
will be out on the floor.
We'll be out in the
Playground area.
We're taking questions.
Please go to the sandbox
talks that we mentioned.
Please look up the DevBytes.
CHET HAASE: And also,
please give feedback
on this session and
all the sessions
that you're seeing
at the conference.
Go into the app or go
onto the I/O website
and you can do it directly
in the Session pages there,
and I think that's it.
Thanks for coming.
DAN SANDLER: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]